we've got the inequality negative x
times the expression 2x minus 14 is
greater than or equal to 24.
so i encoura encourage you to pause this
video now and think about what the
solution set to this inequality would
actually be and actually plot the
solution set on a number line
so i'm assuming you've given a go at it
so now let's just try to simplify this a
little bit so on the left hand side we
could distribute we could distribute
this negative x
and so if we did that we would get
negative 2 negative 2 x squared negative
times a negative is positive plus 14 x
is greater than or equal to 24.
now i'm going to put the i'm going to
subtract 24 from both sides just so that
we just have a 0 here and then we can
think about factoring what we have here
on the left so we have negative 2 x
squared plus 14 x i'm going to subtract
24 from both sides so minus 24 is
greater than or equal to i've subtracted
24 from the right as well so that's
going to be greater than or equal to
0.
now i don't like i don't like having
this
negative 2 out front so what i want to
do is i want to divide the left hand
side by negative 2 but i can't just
divide the left hand side only by
negative 2 i have to divide the right
hand side by negative 2 as well
and any time i multiply or divide both
sides of an inequality by a negative
number it's going to flip the inequality
so if i divide both sides by negative 2
i'm going to be left with
x squared positive x squared
minus so i'm dividing by negative 2. so
minus
7 x plus
and now since i divided by negative 2
i'm going to flip this inequality is
less than or equal to 0 divided by
negative 2 is 0. so that simplified
things a good bit
and now let's see if we can factor this
quadratic expression so two numbers
whose product is positive 12 so that
means they're gonna have the same sign
and whose
and whose sum is negative seven so if
they have the same sign and their sum is
negative seven that tells us that
they're both going to be negative and
let's see negative 3 and negative 4 seem
to fit the build their product is
positive 12 their sum is negative 7. so
we could write this as x minus 3
times x minus 4 is going to be less than
or equal to 0.
so now this is the point that we're
going to do a little bit of interesting
logic if the product of two things is
less than is less than or equal to zero
what does that tell us tell what do we
know about it
well that tells us that either either
one or both of them is 0 or they have
different signs the only way that you're
going to get less than 0 is if 1 is
positive and the other is negative or
one is negative and the other is
positive
so or one is negative is that they have
different signs
so let's write that down
let's write that down so either
either
x minus 3
x minus 3 is
less than or less than
either x minus 3 is less than or equal
to 0 and
and
x minus 4 is greater than or equal to 0
x minus 4 is greater than or equal to 0.
so notice this one is
non-positive this one is non-negative
they're either equal to 0 or they are
have different signs so that's one
situation
or
or the other way around
x minus 3
is non-negative it's greater than or
equal to 0 and
x minus 4 is non-positive
x minus 4 is less than or equal to 0.
once again they're either 0 or different
signs that's all i'm doing with this
little this little logic work right over
here so what are these what is this what
does this simplify to so x minus 3 less
than or equal to 0 add 3 to both sides
you get x is less than or equal to 3
and
x minus 4 is greater than or equal to 0
if you add 4 to both sides of this you
get x is greater than or equal to 4.
so what values of x are going to be less
than or equal to 3
and greater than or equal to 4. well
anything that's less than or equal to
three is not going to be greater than or
equal to four and anything that's
greater than or equal to four is not
going to be less than or equal to three
so there's no x there's no x value that
can satisfy this situation right over
here
there's no x value that will result in
this one being negative and this one
being or this one being non-positive and
this one being non-negative
so let's go to this one right over here
so if we add 3 to both sides we get x is
greater than or equal to three
and
we get adding four to both sides x is
less than or equal to four now does this
make sense that something could be
greater than or equal to three and less
than or equal to four sure for example
well three is greater than or equal to
three and it's less than or equal to
four four is greater than or equal to
four and anything in between so we can
plot the solution set here so this is
actually all that matters because this
one there's no situation which that
would have been true so this is the only
thing this is the only thing that's
going to make this or part true this
part is always going to be false so if
we wanted to make the solution set it
would look something like this
so if this is our possible values of x
so let's say that that is zero so this
is one
two
three
and four
three and four
three
and four
x could be greater than or equal to 3
so it's greater than or equal to 3
but it's also less it also has to be
less than or equal to 4 so we can't just
go all past 4.
also less than or equal less since it's
less than or equal we can color in these
dots less than or equal to four so
anything in this range including three
and four that's why we circled in the
dots this would satisfy this equation
here and if you wanted to think about it
visually hey you know we know that this
type of thing we know that this type of
thing or this type of thing
this type of thing right over here these
are these are parabolas so how would
that relate to this little solution set
that we just thought about right over
here
well if you look at let's let's just
look at one of these let's say we went
to
let's say we went to this form right
over here
so all everything we did this is just
another way of thinking about negative
2x squared plus 14x minus 24 is greater
than or equal to zero
so this is right over here we have a
negative coefficient on the x squared
term that's going to be a downward
opening parabola so when is that greater
than or equal to zero so if if we
thought about the downward opening
parabola it might look something like
this
it might look something like this if
we're not thinking in two dimensions
and this is the this is the if you think
of this as the y-axis right over here so
when is that greater than or equal to
zero what's greater than or equal to
zero it's above the x-axis in this range
for x right over here so that's one way
of thinking about it if we thought about
it from the point of view not of that
parabola
not of that parabola but this parabola
right over here when is x squared minus
7x plus 12 less than or equal to zero
well this is going to be an
upward opening parabola so it has a
positive coefficient here so this
parabola might look something like this
might look something like this when is
it less than or equal to zero well once
again
once again it's less than or equal to
zero in that same range